left in overtime  draymond attacking cutting egypt  beautiful defense unbelievable with the  blocks  draymond committed the foul on the pass  and that was to slow down the break he's  trying to make sure jaws okay  [Applause]  you know draymond green is is rock solid  in his own right listen this game is not  for the faint-hearted  i mean  there are some  huge human beings and strong ones and  memphis has done an incredible job  recovering even when they're beaten to  help john moran ran straight into  draymond and draymond tried to catch him  and keep him upright  you could tell he didn't want him to get  hurt  john moran is still struggling a little  bit  that kyle anderson block was something  special  one point warrior lead